imagine two acres of land that are
covered with Las Vegas history dating
from the 1930s up to present day and
when you walk in they tell a story the
Neon Museum was founded in 1996 and we
rescue signs there are over 200 signs in
the neon boneyard Las Vegas is a town
that is known for imploding all of its
hotels and not preserving its history
because we're always wanting to move on
to the bigger better brighter thing
there's beauty in the worn signs they're
a glimpse into the past you see that
rusted paint you see the broken neon and
it's kind of bittersweet
the folks who designed these are really
master craftsmen they hand blow the neon
that's in them the yucca Motel the
intricate artwork the glassblowing that
had to go into the design of the actual
yucca the start a spire reaching up into
the sky it's becoming an art form that's
going away we preserve a lot of those
memories so people who didn't see the
signs actually on the strip are able to
come here and get a real sense for what
they were like in person
you